when we think of the term extinction we
tend to think of events like what
happened what we believe happened 63
million years ago when a large meteor
hit the earth and killed most of the
dinosaurs and i say most of them because
a lot of animals that we know today
especially birds birds like chickens we
believe are actually descended from some
of the dinosaurs that survived
and other species not just dinosaurs
would have gone extinct but clearly some
other species did survive our ancestors
might have been some type of burrowing
squirrel rodent-like thing that maybe
was under the ground and was able to
survive the immediate shocks and then
somehow find food even when the earth
was covered by dust and there wasn't a
lot of photosynthesis going on but they
were able to survive somehow
what we're going to do in this video
though is think about more subtle notion
of extinction it's not always caused by
these massive changes into the
environment
but one thread one theme that we will be
talking about in extinction is that the
environment is to some degree always
changing and when there is variation in
a population so i'm going to draw some
variation as i do with the different
colored circles if the environment
changes gradually or in certain slow
ways there will often times be variants
members of the population that will be
more likely to succeed than others and
so those variants that are more suitable
for those changes in the environment
well they will reproduce more they will
survive more they will become the
dominant variant and over time they can
even become a new species and so over
time you have species won't go extinct
but they would be adapting or maybe even
evolving into other species that are
more suited to the environment
but our meteorite dinosaur example shows
us that change is not always gradual and
clearly in a situation where the sky is
burning as you have in the dinosaur
example very few organisms are going to
be able to adapt to those types of
circumstances
but you can also have fast change that
might not seem so fast to us as human
beings
for example this chart right over here
shows extinctions since 1500 and i
encourage you to pause this video and
make sure you're processing what is
going on here because that's a skill in
and of itself but it's really
interesting this tells us the cumulative
percentage of species driven extinct
over the last 500 years or so and so you
can see relative to the species that
were there in 1500 if we follow let's
say the line for amphibians amphibians
it looks like someplace between two and
two and a half percent of all species of
amphibians have gone extinct this is not
saying two to two and a half percent of
the amphibians have died this is saying
the species of amphibians they don't
exist anymore that variant of amphibian
genotypes don't exist in our world
anymore
and it's pretty bad for amphibians but
we can see it's pretty bad for other
types of animals as well
and you might say well this isn't so bad
two to two to two and a half percent but
once again these are entire species that
we will never see again and what's also
troubling is how these curves are just
rocketing upwards and some of you all
might be thinking isn't there always
some baseline level of extinction maybe
this isn't so much worse than that
baseline and what's interesting about
this graphic here is it shows us the
baseline this little gray square they're
saying that's the cumulative percentage
of species based on background rate of
0.1 to 2 extinctions per million species
per year and so you see the baseline in
this little gray right down here if we
didn't have unusual amounts of
extinction we would just be charting
roughly close to this line but you can
see since 1500 we have gone well above
it and we know why this is happening
their environments are changing very
very quickly and who is the main culprit
here of changing the environments very
very quickly
well what group's population has really
expanded over the last 500 years and you
would of course say
human beings
and human beings it's not just where
they live and they're taking habitats
away you can imagine this environment is
very different than the environment of
what modern-day los angeles would have
been say 500 years ago
and it's not just where we live it's
also the food we need and we do need
food but that takes up ecosystems
environments where other animals might
have lived and it could be a dramatic
change where they can't live anymore and
so human land and agricultural land use
is a major source of extinctions but on
top of that we go into the sea and we
sometimes will over fish that can be a
source of extinction
lack of diversity as more and more
species learn to live with humans and
maybe our lack of diversity we only have
one we only have a few types of crops a
few types of cattle that we grow there
might be certain species that live well
with them that are able to live off of
them but they might not have as much
variation because the ecosystem is so
not diverse and so if there's some
change the species won't have the
variation necessarily to survive
on top of that you throw in things like
pollution global warming invasive
species and you can see why these curves
are going up in a very very very
troubling way
and i will add this isn't just for us to
care about animals although that is a
good motivation for us to care about the
species because once the species is gone
you're never going to get it back again
but in general
the less diversity that earth as a whole
has it means that our ecosystems are
going to become less and less robust to
change